well looks like that government shutdown
is pretty much over we'll discuss how it
all comes to an end today plus we'll
talk about President Trump who
apparently has some pretty good grounds
to shut down the Mueller investigation
or at least some new ones and Hollywood
can't stop ripping on Milania Milania of
all people I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
by the end of last week I decided that
while the rest of the world didn't
deserve Disneyland I certainly did so I
took my children to Disneyland yesterday
so I'm in a good mood because I got to
watch my kids have a really good time
and and I got to pawn them off on the
grandparents for a few minutes as well
so it was really wonderful we will get
to all of the late-breaking news and
there is some that is breaking right now
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at stamps.com
so stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer we use it here at the
office over at Daily wire not only does
it save us time because we don't
actually have to go over to the post
office it also gets us better deals on
virtually everything right stamps that
come has postage discounts that you
can't get at the post office and it's a
fraction of the cost of those super
expensive postage meters they send you
one of those postage meters when you try
the stamps comm service with our special
offer which includes a four week trial
plus postage and the a digital scale it
is convenient it's easy it's reliable
and it's efficient stamps comm sends you
a digital scale it automatically
calculates your exact postage so you
never overpay or under pay for postage
again and increate that stamps calm
accounts in minutes online no equipment
at least no long-term commitments it's a
fraction of the cost by the way of doing
other mail services it's just fantastic
so stamps comm check it out right now
stamps.com anyone you want to get this
deal this four-week deal that is the
four week trial plus postage ends a
digital scale click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro again click on that microphone
type in Shapiro and you will get that
four week free trial plus postage and a
digital scale which is pretty awesome so
check that out special offer so you're
gonna wanna do that save your business a
lot of money save you a lot of time
doesn't matter how much you love the
post office you probably don't have the
time to stand in line there so check out
stamps calm and use promo code Shapiro
when you click on the microphone okay so
here we are apparently Mitch McConnell
has made a new offer to Democrats on the
government shutdown and they are going
to pursue it they're going to they're
going to go for it what exactly was his
new offer
so one last we left our epic story our
epic story last week it looked like the
Democrats were going to run this
government shutdown into the ground
their goal here was to make sure that
Trump was in the middle of a government
shutdown on the first anniversary of his
inauguration
they're outside goal may have been to
make this thing last beyond the
inauguration should be on
the State of the Union address so the
Trump would actually have to speak about
the State of the Union in the middle of
a government shutdown that looks like
that's about to end and when I say about
tenth I mean like right now as we are
recording this show it looks like
they're about to take a vote that will
end the government shutdown which lasted
all in all three days two and a half
days and that comes to an end as Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader
offers the Democrats virtually nothing
he says we will have a short-term CR
that continuing resolution that funds
the government through February 8th so
it takes us past the State of the Union
address and he says before we get there
we will have a vote on tattoes who will
try another three weeks to come up with
a vote on zakah if not then I guess
we'll have another government shutdown
on February 8th when Democrats tried to
attach deck legislation to the
government did to the government budget
to the continuing resolution remember
that's how this whole thing went down in
the first place we needed to fund the
government the Democrats said we're not
going to fund the government unless you
give us daca unless you give us Obama's
executive amnesty and shrine in law
Republicans said we're not gonna do that
unless you give us some concessions
Democrats said no and then we went into
this government shutdown that started
Friday night and is over by Monday
morning so it really is not even worth
the worth the time here here was Chuck
Schumer last week blaming Trump for it
suggesting that it was all Trump's fault
this government shutdown I love the the
shutdown clock on CNN
yeah I came back online Saturday night
and but when I left for Sabbath in the
government had not yet shut down and I
came back on Saturday night and lo and
behold everything was the same like
literally all of the things were the
same hey no one's check had not gone out
it's that you have to wait till the
first of the month from people's checks
to not go out people were still going to
receive their Social Security the
government is still gonna collect all of
its revenue you know the government was
gonna continue to function a 90 percent
of the government continues to function
during a government shutdown
88 to 90 percent of the government
continues to function as essential
services during government shutdown and
yet we were supposed to believe look at
that counter on CNN that this was the
end of the world right oh my god we're
counting down to Armageddon the asteroid
is finally gonna hit earth here was
Chuck Schumer blaming Trump for it
although Trump really had a little to do
with it the Senate Minority Leader who
thought that he was gonna get a big win
out of this now it's possible Schumer
can still get a win out of this if Mitch
McConnell then makes a bad DAC a deal
right he didn't say it was really the
threat of my it was really the threat of
my government shutdown that forced the
Republicans into a bad deal they didn't
want to redo this in February so a lot
depends on what comes next but here's
Senate Minority Leader Schumer going
after Trump Americans know why the
dysfunction is kering a dysfunctional
president hence we are in a trump
shutdown and party leaders who won't act
without them only president Trump can
end it we Democrats are at the table
ready to negotiate the president needs
to pull up a chair
and end this shutdown okay so the
president did not in fact have to pull
up a chair and end the shutdown Chuck
Schumer ended the shutdown the White
House was doing a pretty good job of
undermining the Democratic claims on
this the Democrats were basically making
two claims one Republicans are
responsible for the shutdown - we have
to shut down the government to get data
those claims are not coherent you cannot
claim both right they they're sort of in
conflict with one another anytime
there's a government shutdown that one
party is responsible for it in this case
it was the Democrats who were
filibustering right the Republicans had
the votes do you get past the government
shutdown to fund a continuing resolution
Democrats were forcing that bar to go up
to 60 votes as opposed to 51 in the
Senate through use of the filibuster you
can't argue we're shutting down the
government because it's so important to
shut down the government and also it's
the other side's fault the government is
shutting down
right because message number one we're
shutting down the government for the
time the priority suggests the
government shutdown is less important
than the other priority message number
two it's your fault suggest the
government shutdown is a terrible thing
and should never happen in any case so
yeah a stupid move by the Democrats here
was the white house comment line the
White House did something clever when
you call the white house comment line no
one picks up the phone no one picked up
the phone before but now they left an
outgoing message saying the reason we're
not here is because okay I love that I
have to admit I really like that I think
that that is good politics I think what
the White House is doing by simply
messaging it outright is smart Mike
Pence did the same thing he was speaking
in from the military and he was asked
about about pay to American troops and
here's what he had to say I'm sure
you're all aware of what's going on in
Washington DC
despite bipartisan support for a budget
resolution I know
in the senate is decided to play
politics with military pay which you
deserve better you and your families
shouldn't have to worry for one minute
about whether you're gonna get paid as
you serve in the uniform of the United
States so know this your president your
vice president and the American people
are not gonna put up with it okay so
that was you know all of this is smart
politicking by the White House the the
brood of those Breughel politicking came
courtesy of Trump himself so the Trump
administration released an ad accusing
Democrats of being complicit in all
murders by illegal immigrants basically
suggesting that the the Democrats are
upholding the rights of illegal
immigrants to stay in the country over
funding of our military and then going
even further President Trump is right
build the wall deployed criminals stop
illegal immigration now Democrats who
stand in our way will be complicit in
every murder committed by illegal
immigrants president Trump will fix our
border and keep our families safe okay
so this is what this is paid for by by
Trump for president so this is his
reelection campaign and he's running a
full ad basically saying side with the
illegal immigrants don't sides don't
side with legal immigrants side with
members of our military side with with
the people who need to be funded by the
budget this is hardcore politicking but
I kind of like it I'll admit it you know
people get very uptight about the Willie
Horton ad which was taken out against
Michael Dukakis who allowed a guy on
furlough who then went out Willie Horton
and killed like a William Horton I guess
and then killed a couple of people is my
understanding and there was an ad that
was quite brutal and it really hurt
Michael Dukakis people are saying this
ad is too much I don't see what's what's
politically stupid about the ad most
Americans agree with this they don't
want Democrats standing up for illegal
immigrants in the country for no reason
they're not they're not up for that in
the idea of Democrats siding with you
legal immigrants over American citizens
I think strikes them as weird that's why
you know Paul Ryan came out he said he
didn't think that this ad was
necessarily productive but it was
productive I mean it actually did help
force the Democrats into a corner they
were not winning this government
shutdown at least in terms of the public
debate well they're certainly not
helping us keep the government open
they're certainly not helping us getting
to a solution and immigration when you
shut down the government you can stop
negotiating an immigration reform
they're complicit with not getting
things done I'm not gonna comment I just
saw that I don't know if that's
necessarily productive
it's no secret the president strong
views on immigration but what is not
productive is a pointless government
shutdown that the Senate Democrats have
foisted on this country ok so you know I
I disagreed with Ryan here I think it
was productive during the government
shutdown you got to bring the bricks and
you got to hit each other with them I
mean that's that's basically what Obama
did during the last government shutdown
now Trump did I think the White House
did a fine job handling this what comes
next is going to be questionable because
again Mitch McConnell has offered a deal
so I'm gonna talk about that deal in one
second and what has to happen here
because now the onus is sort of on Trump
and so it'll be interesting to see this
is the first time the Republicans are
sort of gonna be divided on politics on
any matter of serious consequence they
were divided on Obamacare repeal there
was confusion I think that there may be
similar confusion I guess the second
time there may be similar confusion over
immigration I'll explain that in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsor is over at Skillshare so
Skillshare is the place for you to
broaden and deepen your resume that is
what Skillshare does they encourage
listeners to use 2018 to learn new
skills and make this year their best
year let the best year yet Skillshare is
an online learning platform with over
18,000 classes and designed business
technology and more whether you're
trying to just deepen your professional
skill set make a resume better or start
a new side business Skillshare keeps you
learning in 2018 and beyond and once you
start taking the class you're not going
to want to stop we've taken SEO classes
here about search engine optimization
we've taken classes on data analytics
we've taken all sorts of classes over
here from Skillshare I took one even in
watercolor Skillshare is offering my
listeners a limited time offer of three
months of skill shop for just 99 cents
to go to sign up go to skill shared comm
Shapiro 99 again that's Shapiro
it's Skillshare comm slash Shapiro 99
that skill shared comm slash Shapiro 99
when you do you got three months of
skill share for only 99 cents it's a
great deal you're gonna want to leave it
as soon as the as soon as the offer is
up you're gonna want to continue
maintaining it simply because it's so
good
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro 99 and
make your new year better than your last
one was okay so speaking of the
Republicans being confused on this what
comes next after the government shutdown
so as I say Mitch McConnell has promised
that there will be a vote on immigration
right that there will be a vote on
immigration at some point here before
February 8 what does that actually look
like so the only deal that is currently
on the table
the only deal
it's currently being discussed is a bill
from Jeff Flake Republican of Arizona
dick Durbin Democrat of Illinois and
Lindsey Graham Republican of South
Carolina and it would according to the
hill offer a pathway to citizenship for
so-called dreamers and permission to
stay in the country for their parents
and what would Republicans get in return
for basically legalizing this could be
up to eight million people they get two
billion dollars in border security
funding can be a giant fail of a bill a
giant fail there would be no serious
changes to the visa diversity lottery
there'd be no serious changes to the to
the chain migration laws
there'd be no serious changes to
immigration basically would be Trump
caving on daca knowing the deadline is
coming up in March and knowing that
another deadline is coming up in terms
of the continuing resolution as of
February 8th now the White House opposes
that deal they say 8 million illegal
immigrants could be allowed to stay is
according to Daily wire Graham meanwhile
is attacking the special advisor to
President Trump so Trump is being torn I
think in within his administration a
little bit over this particular issue
the Lindsey Graham of course is the most
dovish of all Republicans on immigration
he says that Stephen Miller who's one of
the president's special advisers on
immigration is undermining the deal now
I have to say I know Stephen I know I'm
I wouldn't say like really really well
but I know Stephen relatively well would
there was a dinner that I was at in 2014
and the dinner was Jeff Sessions and
Coulter Stephen Miller me and like one
other guy and we were just sitting
around talking immigration for deep into
the night and Miller and Coulter were
very much on the same page even in
Milton and Ann are our friends I believe
and Stephen is named Wang kind of
immigration he's also incredibly
hardline and immigration he's also in
the president's ear on immigration the
president is a lot harder core on
immigration that he was even three years
ago Lindsey Graham is very upset with
Stephen Miller and he and he lashed out
at him over the fact that Miller and the
Trump administration are putting a crimp
in his plans with regard to this
immigration shutdown as long as Stephen
Miller's in charge of negotiating
immigration we're going nowhere he's
been an outlier for years okay so the
truth is that that Miller is a very
hardcore guy at immigration but Graham
is also an outlier he's much more dovish
than the rest of the party this is just
his latest and greatest attempt to move
toward amnesty the the White House is
firing back on Graham directly Hogan
Ginley said quote as long as senator
chooses to support legislation that size
of people in this country illegally and
unlawfully instead of our own American
citizens were going nowhere he's been an
outlier for years so this sets up the
conflict right this sets up the conflict
cuz Democrats are gonna offer some sort
of pittance in exchange for daca
Gutierrez I think this is um I'm
training members luis Gutierrez Democrat
of Illinois he came out he said about
the government shutdown but he's really
talking about daca
then maybe we'll give Trump a little bit
of funding for his wall if that's what
we have to do in order to make sure that
the dreamers stay then fine any deal
approved by luis Gutierrez is a garbage
deal okay that's the rule of thumb luis
Gutierrez is the most dovish member of
congress on immigration and particularly
illegal immigration here's what he had
to say look I think the wall is a
monumental waste of taxpayers money and
it's to build a monument to to stupidity
and and it's just idiotic having said
that if that's what it's going to take
in order to put 800,000 young men and
women in this country dreamers and put
them in a safe place and put them on a
course to full integration in our
society if that's what the hostage
takers of the dreamers if that's their
ransom call I say pay it okay so if he's
saying pay off the wall give him a
couple billion bucks for the wall and
then we'll get the dreamers in that's
the deal that no Republican should take
again this is a great lip mist test any
time luis Gutierrez for something you
run the other way you just run the other
way and one of the problems here is that
for President Trump when it comes to
negotiation he has proved not to be
particularly adept at negotiation with
Democrats remember he signed off on a
budget deal last year he undermined Paul
Ryan and Mitch McConnell and what far
more dovish on immigration I mean on the
budget then his fellow Republicans would
have had him do he got Republicans
almost in trouble on this government
shutdown like he tweeted out over the
weekend this right here's what he
tweeted quote great to see how hard
Republicans are fighting for our
military and safety at the border the
Devens just wants illegal immigrants to
pour into our nation unchecked if
stalemate continues Republicans should
go to 51% nuclear option and vote on
real long-term budget no continuing
resolutions
okay this is stupid strategy what he was
doing in the middle here the whole point
was to blame Democrats for the shutdown
not to put the onus on Republicans to
end the filibuster by going to the
nuclear op
which of course would grant Democrats
basically the precedent to do the exact
same thing when they get into power
again which eventually they will I mean
the chances of Republicans rule forever
are extraordinarily low I would say even
chances the Republican rule in midterms
are diminished so you know Trump is not
great at negotiation and this is the
dirty little secret
Trump is good at what he's good at
signing things right saying stuff Trump
is not great when it comes to these
negotiations in Congress and so he
should really stay out of them but now
it looks like there's a divide in the
Republican side of the aisle you got the
Republican doves on immigration and
Mitch McConnell has pledged to give a
vote so what if the only bill that comes
up is Graham's bill what are the
Republicans in the House dudes they
stymie it so the Republicans in the
house turned down the Graham Bell did
they fight against the Graham Bell do
they say we'll go to another government
shutdown and then the Democrats say hey
listen the Republicans and we voted for
a bill that would have averted the
government shutdown and you guys
wouldn't do it the Republicans have the
stones to do that in the house after the
Senate passes something and then does
Trump have the capacity to actually veto
something and that's the big question
here Trump has never had to use his veto
pen Grover Norquist during the election
cycle made the suggestion that Trump's
presidency was going to essentially be
an autopen that Republicans would put up
whatever they want in front of him and
he would sign it and so far that's been
exactly the case my Trump hasn't had to
veto anything because he has a
Republican Congress but what happens
when his supposedly cherished priorities
on immigration
run up against the reality that a lot of
Republicans disagree with him is he
gonna veto such a bill is his tough talk
anything but tough talk or is it just
going to be that he lets it go pass no
he's made signals in the past that he's
gonna sign anything Congress puts in
front of him including a bad daca deal
if he does that he'll lose a lot of his
base at least on immigration I don't
think that a huge percentage will care
but the Ann Coulter's Mickey couses of
the world they'll be very upset
obviously there give me a lot of people
who feel like he betrayed them if after
all of this hubbub over Obama's
executive amnesty Republicans you know
brought Republican Congress and
Republican president Rhee enshrine it in
response in in favor of two billion
dollars in increased border security
right this is this is not yeah the
urgency is growing and there's a report
today there's a report today that the
border wall prototypes have been sitting
there in the desert doing nothing right
we have a bunch of prototypes they've
been sitting there
and meanwhile there's been a major surge
there's been a major surge in the
illegal immigration and it continues to
grow because the economy is doing better
this is how it always works by the way
you know Obama got a lot of credit for
diminished illegal immigration that was
not because of Obama that was because
the economy was not very good under
Obama for most of his tenure it was only
at the end it started to pick up in any
real way and in the last year of course
it's really been booming so people are
pouring into the country Mexico is not
doing as well so a lot of people are
crossing the border illegally in
December u.s. Border Patrol agents
according to Breitbart apprehended
almost 30,000 illegal immigrants trying
to cross into the country between ports
of entry that beware the border wall is
the the idea that Republicans are going
to cave on anything but that they may
not have a full border wall they may not
get a dented iversity visa lottery the
idea they may not get an ended chain
migration it speaks to the fact that
Trump may not have any serious
principles this is gonna be a real
problem for him this is a it's it's a
serious issue it's a serious problem so
you know I think that this is gonna be
Trump's really first test he hasn't been
tested yet his first test is gonna be
what if Congress disagrees with him what
if Congress decides that they are not
going to what if Congress decides that
they are not going to go along with his
hard core Stephen Miller immigration
plan instead they're gonna go along with
Lindsey Graham it's gonna open to open
up some serious questions inside the
Republican Party and that cannot be good
for for President Trump so while the
government shutdown is a loss for
Schumer as it currently as it currently
stands while the government shutdown
does not look like a big win for
Democrats on this it looks like they're
going down in flames frankly with all of
that said it depends on what comes next
right the fact is that the polling for
Democrats has been bad there's a late
poll that was coming out in the last two
weeks that showed well last week
actually that showed that Republicans
have been picking up serious ground in
the Congressional polling it used to be
Democrats plus 18 just two months ago
now it was Democrats plus seven it's a
major shift in favor of Republicans
that's because of the tax cuts it's also
because Chuck Schumer is doing a bad job
the last thing Democrats want is another
one of these government shutdowns
Republicans do have some leverage here
so I'm encouraging Republicans to not
cave do not cave if Democrats shut down
the government again they shut down the
government again but do not give them a
bill in the Senate it's going to be
something they can't
past the house and get past President
Trump you need to go with Trump's agenda
here at least you need to go with what
Trump stated agenda was here because
caving preemptively is really really
foolish so here we go now let's move on
to let's move on to them the Mueller
investigation which has become more and
more of a debacle over time more news
that just is not good for the Mueller
investigation first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at ranked on so
you've heard me talk about rings
innovative home security camera devices
for for quite a while here they've been
sending us actual footage of ring
busting crooks in the act this is one
that I want to share with you so here is
the here's a little bit of clip okay
there's a crazy-looking guy who walks up
to a home the first thing you're gonna
hear is him kicking in the door and then
the homeowner catches him and starts
talking to him over the ring device hey
leave my house or I'm calling the police
okay what you need to do here's my house
stop now or I'm calling the police why
would you tell me that because you're
trying to push my door in leave now I'm
calling the police okay well I mean I am
the Senate I'm the police that this guy
is so this will ring calm can do for you
obviously the police then show up but
this guy would have continued bashing in
the door if the homeowners voice hadn't
come on and started talking this crazy
loon bag I mean this guy obviously has
serious problems I hope he gets the help
that he needs but I do have to laugh a
little bit at the fact that the guy is
asking the homeowner why is he talking
to him you literally just tried to kick
in his door and then when he says I am
the police with all of his three teeth
I'm no no you're not that's a good thing
they had the ring yeah when you can see
what's going on your front door and it
gives you a lot more leeway to stop
crime pretty empowering with the ring
floodlight and spotlight cams you can
build a ring of security around your
entire property ring less you protect
your home no matter where you are you
can share your clips to help keep your
neighbors on the lookout for suspicious
activity thieves can't just hide with
rings to stop crime before it happens
help make your neighborhood safer with
ring save up to 105
bucks on a ring of security Canon ring
comm / Ben that's ring.com / Ben again
$150 off when you go to ring comm / Ben
and you can be like that home owner and
not like the guy who wasn't home whose
house was probably busted into by some
guy looking exactly like that okay so
this is actually big news that's
breaking over the weekend representative
Jim Jordan from Ohio he's gonna be on
Facebook live with us a little bit later
today because he wants to sort of give
us the update on what's going on in the
Mueller investigation there are a couple
of pieces of breaking news that are
quite crazy with regard to the Mueller
investigation a lot of coincidences
piling up with regard to the Mueller
investigation how is conducted so you
recall a lot of them come down to this
one guy Peter stroke previous Raza can
smell STR Z okay I have no idea how to
pronounce this others pronounce a truck
schrick I'll just pronounce it
differently every time make fun of his
name in any case this guy is an FBI
agent he was having an affair with
another FBI agent named Lisa Paige they
were both working on the Trump Russia
probe so we know that Strasse k-- was
involved in the hillary clinton email
investigation we know he had been
involved in launching the Trump
investigation and we know that he was
staffed on it as well now we also know
that Strock texted Paige on August 15
2016 regarding Trump quote I want to
believe the path you threw out for
consideration in deputy FBI director
Andrew McCabe's office that there's no
way he gets elected but I'm afraid we
can't take that risk
it's like an insurance policy in the
unlikely event you die before you're 40
which makes it sound a lot like the
Trump collusion investigation could be a
way of stopping Trump's candidacy right
it's an insurance policy against
stopping Trump from becoming president
now we learned that stroke and Paige
send each other messages suggesting they
knew before the FBI had reported to then
Attorney General Loretta Lynch that
Clint was going to be exonerated on July
1st 2016 you recall Obama Attorney
General Loretta Lynch announced she'd do
whatever FBI director Comey told her to
do that announcement followed a tarmac
meeting in Arizona between Loretta Lynch
and Bill Clinton that day
stroke texted Paige quote timing looks
like hell Paige responded it's a real
Profile in Courage
since she knows that no charges will be
brought she's not supposed to know no
charges will be brought right the FBI
was not supposed to be telling the DOJ
what their judgments on this case was
until the judgment was out but
apparently Comey and the rest of the FBI
had been regularly informing the
goj that hilary would not be prosecuted
which is super corrupt and the
coincidences don't stop there hey this
is a crazy story this is the most insane
coincidence of all so something like 400
pages of text messages between FBI
agents have been delivered to the Senate
Oversight Committee Senator Ron Johnson
of Wisconsin he announced on Monday that
the FBI had somehow failed to deliver
months of text between stroke and page
text beginning at December 14th 2016
ending May 17 2017 what happened that
day that's the exact day that Mueller
was appointed to head the investigation
so in other words all text before
Mueller took over the investigation from
December to May were deleted the FBI
says they were lost in a technical
glitch how do you lose just the text
that we need how's that you lose
precisely the text that determine the
shaping of that Russia collusion
investigation during that period of time
you had Trump's inauguration all of the
activity with Mike Flynn Mike Flynn's
firing the mana fort I believe that the
man of fort investigation will ran into
into high gear the firing of James Comey
well all of this stuff was happening in
that time and we have none of the texts
between stroke and Carter page
none of them so representative Jordan
has called for a second special counsel
to investigate the first special counsel
now he tweeted out earlier today that it
was time for some sort of investigation
at first the IRS destroyed emails
pivotal to our investigation of their
political targeting now the FBI quote
unquote failed to preserve tax between
Peter stroke and Lisa page following the
2016 election the time is for a second
Special Counsel is now well yes yes I
believe that it is I believe that it is
I mean just for the sake of my own peace
of mind and the sake for the sake of
peace of mind the American people
there's a lot of suspicion of this
investigation now there would have been
any way but that suspicion is is really
high particularly after the the
so-called memo that people who want
released that's supposed to shed light
on how the FISA warrant was originally
garnered from the from the Obama
administration to check out Carter page
and now you have all these deleted FBI
texts and you have these texts between
stroke and page C and and Lisa page no
relation to Carter suggesting that there
was a sort of conspiracy afoot in all of
this it's just it's all insane I mean
how was this investigation run this
badly
now Mueller was
therefore all of this right he fired
lisa page any fired peter stroke upon
taking the office that's Angela Muller
but you have sort of a fruit of the
poisonous tree thing going on now in in
law there's something called fruit of
the poisonous tree basically the idea is
that if I break into your house illegal
and the police I break in your house
illegally and I find evidence that you
murdered someone I can't use that
evidence in court because it's fruit of
the poisonous tree because I broke the
law in order to obtain the evidence well
the same thing sort of holds true with
regard to this investigation if the
investigation was launched on the basis
that there was a democratic Apple
Research file from fusion GPS that was
used for political reasons by the FBI to
target Carter page and therefore the
Trump campaign and if it turns out
that's separate from that the FBI was
exonerating Hillary Clinton for
political reasons at the same time
they're investigating Trump and if it
turns out that's separate from that
they're members of the FBI who are
texting each other that the Trump
Mueller and that the Trump collusion
investigation was actually a way to
prevent Trump from becoming president
and and if after that it turns out that
the FBI purposefully deleted months of
texts between two of their key agents
and all of this I think the American
people have a right to know and the
American people might have some serious
questions all of this calls into serious
question our faith in our institutions
it was our lack of faith that this is
deeply troubling to me the lack of faith
in our institutions that already exists
is deep and abiding it's a serious
serious problem right the lack of faith
in our institutions is what led to the
rise of Donald Trump it's what leads
it's it's frankly what's led to the
growth of government because people
instead of instead of looking at the
institution's and figuring those
institutions are corrupt take all the
power away from them instead they say
well if we just had a guy who will break
all the rules and use the power of those
institutions to reinstall virtue
everything will be great
unfortunately the human tendency is not
toward liberty when it comes to misuse
of institutions it's toward the belief
that those institutions can be corrected
if they have the proper leadership the
founders disagreed but that's
unfortunately how most people think none
of this is good right you want
institutions that are worthy of our
trust right now I'm not sure the FBI is
completely worthy of our trust if what
we're hearing is true the Obama DOJ
certainly was not worthy of our trust
now for all the flack that Jeff sessions
has gotten Jeff sessions is DOJ has
operated much more along the lines of
law than the Obama DOJ is I mean you
literally have the sitting Attorney
General of the United States calling
himself the President of the United
States his wingman right then that is
not exactly what we want from the head
of the DOJ and the chief law enforcement
officer in the country all these
institutions now need a thorough
cleansing top-to-bottom they they they
all need to feel clean to the American
people I don't know if Trump is capable
of doing that by the way it may be left
up to the next president because Trump
is so politicized because his presidency
is so despised by so many anything he
does is not gonna be seen as cleaning
house except by members of his base and
maybe some Republicans but that said
another oversight investigation of this
of this investigation may be necessary
the Mueller investigation itself may be
fatally flawed at this point we'll have
to see what comes out from it
Democrats are hoping there's a killer
shot in there if there is no kill shot
then this is going to be seen I think
half rightly as Trump says is one of the
greater political witch hunts in modern
American political history if nothing
major comes out of this and went on for
a year and it was Democrats in the media
propping up this nonsense then there's
gonna be hell to pay there will be
political hell to pay and Democrats will
have made a huge huge mistake one that
in its inception goes back again as
always to Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama okay so in just a minute I want to
talk about the women's March that
happened over the weekend I want to talk
about the pro-life march that happened
over the weekend things I like things I
hate a Federalist paper but first we're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of our of our
show live you get the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live you get the rest of
Andrew Cleveland's show live is to be
part of our mailbag on Fridays when we
have conversations with with me and
Knowles in Cleveland you get to be you
get to ask us live questions which is
awesome you also get to get our annual
subscription our annual subscription is
cheaper than monthly instead of $9.99 a
month which is like 120 bucks a year
look at that math boom instead you get
ninety nine dollars a year gets you a
full annual subscription to the daily
wire which comes along with this the
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr the
world famous often imitated never
duplicated world famous tumblr you got
that as well if you want to just listen
later iTunes SoundCloud Google Play
stitcher you can check any of those out
and you can get our podcasts there
please subscribe to our youtube channel
as well we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so as we speak right now it's worth
noting that dick durbin is thanking
Democratic senators for shutting down
the government over daca he's trying to
make excuses for why he led them into
the suicide strategy into this box
canyon of politics
he said you suck your nuts out and I'm
gonna go on record even if it's hard to
explain back home
yeah that's code for it's hard to
explain back home and then we made a big
mistake here and then he dumped on Trump
a lot and talked about how Trump was
really bad but Democrats obviously lost
on this one then they all they lost
Louise Gutierrez has tweeted out quote
if I have to give a brick if I have to
give a brick for every dreamer Trump
releases if it offends me but I'll help
build the wall if that's what it takes
but now that we have offered the wall
they want cuts to legal immigration
right so now he's saying that he's very
angry that Republicans are gonna stick
to Republican principles as well they
should as well they should so we'll see
how all of this plays out and whether
the Republicans have the stomach to
actually stand up for all of this so I
guess that the the next CR the next
continuing resolution is Toby rave so if
you enjoyed this government shutdown
you'll get government shutdown to the
revenge on February 8th unless we are
unless there's some sort of deal that
gets cut
okay so meanwhile over the weekend there
were a couple of big marches one was the
pro-life march the other was the women's
March the pro-life March is one of the
great events that happens every year
hundreds of thousands of people show up
in Washington DC to protest the roe v--
wade decision for those who don't know
the roe v wade decision is legitimately
one of the worst judicial decisions in
the history of the United States it
stands up alongside Dred Scott as an
egregious violation of human rights as
well as a breach of constitutional
protocol there is nothing in the
Constitution nothing zero things about
your right to kill your own baby nothing
in fact there's a good case to be made
that the the Constitution of the United
States which is dedicated to protecting
equal protection of the laws that that
should apply to unborn children that the
idea that you should be able to kill a
child for convenience is just plainly
insane this is a case the pro-life
movement makes they say the Fourteenth
Amendment guaranteeing equal protection
of the laws should apply to unborn
children the roe v wade decision which
is based on a bunch of pseudoscience
about what babies what fetal development
looks like and when babies are viable
and all of this stuff it's sure not
it's been garbage forever it's based on
a series of cases that established a
non-existent right to privacy now there
is a right against unreasonable search
and seizure in the Constitution of the
United States that is not the same thing
as a right to privacy you do not have a
blanket right to privacy certainly not
one that extends to you doing something
as non private as going out to a doctor
and having that doctor perform a surgery
on a on you that kills a baby that is
not a private act okay it is not a
private your medical records may be
private right and and they're guarded
against government unreasonable search
and seizure but if you are acting on a
third party way under libertarian
principles libertarians can take a
pro-life position here if that baby is a
baby you do not get to harm it just as
if I am a person you do not get to harm
me but the latter is probably more
questionable than the former so the fact
that the as far as the humanity of the
people involved the fact is that the
pro-life March it's it's demonstrative
of the fact there are a lot of people in
the United States who still care about
civil rights it's so funny the media do
this routine where they talk about the
great civil rights issues of our time
now they're always trying to make things
I can to liken make analogies between
between race and the and women's issues
or race and gay issues or race and
transgender issues none of these
comparisons hold women are not treated
remotely like black people were treated
in the United States today gay people
are not treated remotely like black
people were treated in the United States
also the idea that that homosexual acts
are on the same par as color of skin is
inane and it just logically does not
hold to suggest that even if there were
government regulation of homosexual
activity which I oppose by the way right
I'm a libertarian I oppose that but even
if there were that is not the same thing
as regulations on somebody's race right
race is an immutable characteristic
sexual activity is activity right your
orientation may be immutable may be I
mean there's there's some scientific
evidence that goes both ways but there's
no question that activity is mutable
right all activity is mutable so it's
not quite the same thing as I'm
discriminating against you because of
the color of your skin so that analogy
doesn't hold either the transgender
analogy certainly doesn't hold the idea
that transgender people in the United
States are being treated like black
people in the United States or that
these two things are akin that the the
disorder that is gender identity
disorder or gender dysphoria whatever
you wish to call it that is akin to
being black is just in
say again there is no manifestation in
behavior with regard to with regard to
being black there is manifestation and
behavior with regard to transgenderism
inherently so long as you are claiming
you're a member of the opposite sex in
any case there is one civil rights issue
that is very much akin to the civil
rights issues that are facing black
folks and that is the treatment of
unborn children as second-class citizens
or worse as channel right the truth is
that when you're talking about the
murder of unborn citizens what you are
talking about is more on par with
slavery than it is with Jim Crow you're
talking about killing you're talking
about the treatment of people as
property right well you're talking about
when you say that a mother has the right
to to abort her baby for any reason
whatsoever is that that baby is her
property and she can dispose of it suo
the people who are marching in
washington d.c deserve the same respect
as civil rights heroes as the media
tried to accord to the women's marchers
i mean the media i've been making this
big deal out of women's marchers again
women have never had it better in the
history of mankind than they have in the
united states today they just have not
okay and anybody who argues with this
knows nothing about world history or
about multiculturalism they're
celebrating cultures very often that
hate women that despise women but the
women's marches nonetheless have been
have been paid honor and tribute by the
vast majority of media outlets that are
given front-page status my understanding
is the attendance was way off this year
from the women's marches last year
because the women's marches last year
were coincidence with with trump's
inauguration they they have millions
people attended those i don't think the
women's marches this year nowhere were
anywhere close to that what what i'm
seeing is that um let's see it looks
like they have a they have a list here
over at heavy calm so in New York is
about 85,000 people I guess that is not
close to what it was last year in
Richmond Virginia is like a thousand
people in Chicago they that Chicago was
the only place where actually increased
apparently the 300,000 people who
participate in the March there were only
about 12,000 people in DC last year
through half a million people half a
million people in LA a lot of people
showed up there are about 700,000 who
participated last year they're about
five hundred thousand participated this
year a lot of board people who feel like
marching on a Sunday the weather was
good yesterday so I guess that if you
have nothing better to do I guess you
can go in March also all these women and
then we're watching the football
so I guess they they left their
boyfriends and husbands at home and
decided to go March for women's rights
while their husbands at home and ate
Cheetos and actually enjoyed themselves
so again the idea of these women are
marching for anything material I'm
wondering what exactly they're marching
for they always say equal pay for equal
work they've achieved equal pay for
equal work
if they're marching for broader
acceptance of opposition to sexual
harassment and sexual assault I don't
know what they're marching for since I'm
not sure who is in favor of sexual
harassment and sexual assault outside of
Hollywood executives and apparently all
of the fellow actors of the actresses
who are speaking at this March
nonetheless Jessica Chastain appeared on
Saturday Night Live to push the women's
marches and here's what she had to say
especially today because this weekend is
the one-year anniversary of the women's
March today hundreds of thousands of
people were out there for the cause and
they are so so brave because it's the
worst flu season ever I wish I could
have been there marching alongside them
ok well March with you Jessica yeah yeah
I'm always wearing practical Footwear
[Music]
[Applause]
okay is this funny did I miss the part
where S&L turned into literally just a
fundraiser for Democrats it's really
really awful remember this on Saturday
Night Live is a show that used to be
funny at some point and now we've got a
bunch of women who can't sing yeah first
of all if you can't sing don't sing okay
I'm a good violinist and I don't make my
violin playing the centerpiece of what I
do because I'm not at the level of
Hilary Hahn right these women cannot
sing at all and yet SNL features them
every week singing I guess that the me2
movement means that they also get to
sing badly but they get to see more
often because I guess the day they're
there social justice warrior ring
Jessica Chastain by the way is
unbelievably wealthy right judge Jessica
Chastain made at least a couple of
million dollars for the Martian and
people are complaining Oh Matt Damon
made 18 million dollars for the Martian
and Jessica Chastain only made a couple
of million bucks for the Martian right
she's in it for like ten minutes I was
just a chest ain't even in the Martian I
can't even remember her being in it
right the entire movie is Matt Damon on
Mars that's the entire film of course he
made more money also Matt Damon happens
to be something called a box-office draw
right nobody goes to see a Jessica
Chastain movie no one I like Jessica
Chastain is an actress I think she's
good but the idea that people went to
see zero dark thirty because they were
desperate to see Jessica Chastain in a
film what is Molly's game earned I want
to look at the earnings from Molly's
game okay Miley's game is now out so
what's it let's look at the let's look
at the box office let's see if we can
get some box office stat for that
massive hit right is now earned
twenty-eight point 1 million dollars
miss Sloan right which she also said she
also starred in last year earn a
whopping nine point 1 million dollars at
the box office ok the last time the I'm
gonna look up Jessica Chastain's I am
IMDB because whenever people complain
about the wage gap in Hollywood it makes
no sense whatsoever all of her films
that have been successful we're
successful because everyone else right
because everyone else in the film is a
box-office draw now that should be
totally Frank about this here are the
films that she started where she was the
leading lady okay woman walks ahead
never even heard of it zookeeper his
wife or nothing miss Sloan a total
box-office bomb
crimson peak hmm the Martian Matt Damon
star made lots of money
ammos
violent year very small film and Oscar
and Oscar Isaac she's very good in it
but again very small film interstellar
she is not the star of it Matthew
McConaughey's the star of it and it's
Christopher Nolan films I made lots of
money the disappearance of Eleanor Rigby
made no money
Salome mama she's mama and Annabelle
okay but but it's it but that is not
actually or no she's Annabelle in the
movie mama which I've never even heard
of zeroes aren't thirty like these are
not big box office draws none of them
zero of these things are big box office
drugs but we're supposed to worry about
her wage gap with Matt Damon okay like
I'm gonna read you Matt Damon's IMDB
okay
okay Matt Damon's IMDB here are the
films that Matt Damon has starred in
over the last few years okay he was the
producer on Jason Bourne which made a
bajillion dollars okay he was also let's
see what did he what he acted oh so he
was he was in Thor Ragnarok where he was
uncredited he was in the great wall
which made a bajillion dollars in China
Jason Bourne made a bajillion dollars
the Martian bajillion dollars
interstellar bajillion dollars I Elysium
which is a big-budget but it busted
you know the guy's actually a box-office
drum then people are like oh well why is
yearning what's the matter hey man okay
what women are marching for if you're
marching for we want to be treated
equally then I'm gonna treat you equal
you suck at singing don't sing ever
again on national TV
okay let's just start with that and also
if you're gonna stand for equality I'd
like half of Jessica Chastain's paycheck
for every movie that she makes because
my goodness all these women on SNL I
mean for the quality and by the way
everyone on SNL should donate their
salary to charity given the fact they
suck so much lately
just an awful it wasn't by the way just
Jessica Chastain the Kirsten Belle over
the weekend there was the the SAG Awards
and I haven't seen this movie three
billboards which is winning all of the
which is winning all the awards have you
seen it yet Mathis so we'll have to see
it no I'll give you my opinion after I
see it because I have a feeling I'm not
going to like it very much that's why
I've been holding off on seeing it but
any case
Kirsten Bell felt the need to slap at
Melania and Melania Trump because why
not I mean it's just it's just such a
fun thing to do
good evening my friends welcome to the
24th Annual Screen Actors Guild Awards
you know there has never been a host for
this award show before yeah it's the
first time first person first lady right
and I honestly never thought that I
would grow up to be the first lady but
you know what I kind of like it I think
my first initiative as first lady will
be cyberbullying because I have yet to
see any progress made on that problem
quite yet and I'm looking at you Tony
Hale you're a bully you guys he's savage
on Twitter I'm serious it's obviously
that's left Melania is leading a cyber
bullying initiative because president
Trump is a bully on Twitter
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha a trump joke yeah okay so
there's that Kristen Bell by the way is
a massive Lib she she loves to plan as
she loves to campaign on behalf of
Planned Parenthood she's very very Pro
pro-choice in Pro abortion also I'm
gonna say something politically
incorrect now okay when when all of
these women are pushing times up and
they're pushing don't sexually harass me
and they're pushing treat me the same as
men and then Kristen Bell wears a dress
that is cut down to the navel I'm just
suggesting to women that if you want men
to treat you in a non-sexual eyes duay
that that may not be the strongest move
the suggestion is now you can dress
however you want and men still shouldn't
treat you in any way other than
respectful but just as it is a point of
risk allocation and as a point of you
don't want to be treated you want to be
treated less in a certain way there's
certain activities that you can do that
will make you treated more in a certain
way okay wear a dress cut down your
navel men are going to look at your
dress differently than if you do not
wear a dress cut down your navel end of
story that's just the way human nature
works again that's not a justification
but it is it is a a hint okay time for
some things I like and then some things
I hate and then a Federalist Papers so
things I like over the weekend
I was I've just started my name's
Brandon Sanderson book I'm a big fantasy
sci-fi fan there are not very good many
good fantasy books is the truth most
fantasy books out of quite terrible now
there are some pretty good sci-fi books
there are a lot of good sci-fi books
actually I would suggest that a lot of
the books in the Star Wars canon are
better than a lot of the sequels they've
been made
Timothy's on books and I'm reading those
when I was younger and I remember really
enjoying those I'll have to go back and
reread them but in any case one of the
better fantasy writers on the scene
today I'd say the best is Brandon
Sanderson he has his new book out called
oath bringer
but Oathbreaker oath bringer I'll check
it out but in any case the old trilogy
that he wrote that's really good is the
Mistborn trilogy I believe they're
making a series out of this now it's
really creative and he does a lot of
world-building so the entire basis of it
is that there's a certain set of people
a certain set of skilled people who
basically swallow metal and then can use
their bodies almost as magnets it's it's
very bizarre but it's really interesting
it's in an alternate reality of course
Brandon Sanderson's very good writer his
books are a little over long but that's
just John respect there's not such a
thing as a fantasy book that is under
long write every fantasy book is 700
pages it sells by the pound not even by
the page but the Mistborn trilogy is
really worth reading so go ahead and
check that out it's a lot of fun ok
other things that I like so I was
ripping on Hollywood earlier but I will
say that the SAG Awards did something
correct they did something better than
the Emmy Awards they actually invited
some of the women who had been
victimized in me too and then they and
then they had them speak so they had
Rosanna Arquette and Marisa Tomei who
paid silent and paid tribute to the
silence breakers I believe Rosanna
Arquette is one of the original women
who alleged something she had alleged
that she was assaulted I believe by
Harvey Weinstein if I'm not incorrect in
any case they actually invited the women
which was something that the Emmys
should have done and they spoke about it
openly which if Hollywood wants to get
past this they should all do Rosanna you
are one of those voices you're one of
the silence breakers and we all owe you
a debt of gratitude
I'm here supporting many women how's er
gentle Ohana Bella Shira Ashley Ashley
judge Daryl Hannah Mira Sorvino so many
Anthony Rapp from happy rap thank you
olivia munn thank you okay so is still
the one who never gets to mention her as
Rose McGowan who had the whole thing
started in the first place she's still
been blackballed by Hollywood so I guess
that she's never gonna be thanked from
the stage but at least they're starting
to bring for the actual woman who did
this as opposed to the posturing from a
bunch of women who didn't actually say
anything about this stuff for years okay
other things that I like so the Eagles
beat the Vikings yesterday which is too
bad I was rooting for the Vikings at
least insofar as I was rooting which is
not very hard but this was pretty funny
so a lot of the Eagles fans had been
climbing then an evening with poles over
there apparently the Eagles fans when
they win have been climbing the actual
like light poles in the city but this
guy had a different experience of the
pole in he was running after the bus in
in Philadelphia after the game and this
is the hardest shot that anybody took
from the minute this is a harder shot
than anybody took from the Minnesota
defense yesterday he's running wound
tough actin tinactin
oh he just takes one right in the kisser
and he's running and OH
hammered Wow okay okay he's running out
for the subway I guess I'm there's no
way not to laugh at that okay it's just
like he's really picking up see what my
question is what he was running for like
it's already it's already moving you're
not gonna like stop the bus or stop the
or stop the car boom okay enjoy that
folks and I guess you just can't enjoy
life the guy's fine by the way at least
from from what I understand or he's dead
I haven't really checked it out but
that's it but that's funny the way
that's going around the internet if
something bad happened to me I would
already know about okay time for a
couple of quick things I hate and then
the Federalist number twelve so
today so what I love about every
government shutdown is well nothing
actually changed for nearly all
Americans the the media suggested that
all would end all would die end of world
okay so this is my favorite aspect the
CNN ran a report about how because of
the government shutdown asteroids could
destroy earth I am not kidding like
Bruce Willis would be on break and he
would not be able to actually sacrifice
himself in favor of Ben Affleck bad move
by the way never sacrifice yourself in
favor of Ben Affleck but the the idea
that that the government would be on
break and then if something terrible
happened we would all die because Trump
and Schumer couldn't come to an
agreement over data the over data
registration or something here's CNN's
report about how an asteroid could
murder us all in our sleep and in space
that same year for more than two weeks
NASA reportedly stopped monitoring
potentially dangerous asteroids a big
one by the way is expected to brush by
Earth on February 4th okay by the idea
by the way that a big one is about to
brush by earth by February 4th I mean
this one is going to miss us by a
bajillion by a bajillion miles ok this
this asteroid is not going to come close
to hitting the it's not gonna come close
to hitting the earth but and if it were
I promise you that the government would
would try to do its best about it we
wouldn't all just die we wouldn't have
like a dinosaur level extinction event
because there is a government shutdown
for three days is it's just ridiculous
it's just ridiculous it's it's not gonna
come particularly close like it misses
us by a huge margin actually it misses
us by a by a huge swath that's so it's
supposed to fly safely past the earth on
February 4th there been a bunch of
asteroids that have been flying past us
but missing us by a fair warning it's
missing us by oh my goodness and they
have a chart here on how on how much
it's missing us by and the answer is 2.6
million miles so a lot a lot okay so
other things that I hate Jimmy Kimmel
again does not understand government
shutdowns and he's just all he does now
is take talking points from Chuck
Schumer again I don't understand why
Hollywood feels the need to do this but
the more they do the better it is for
Trump so I guess good for them keep it
keep it going you're gonna win
Republicans the Congress again here's
Jimmy Kimmel deciding that he needs to
speak out of politics again because
obviously me shellacking him over his a
the other nine times hasn't done
anything hello I'd like a cappuccino
please okay great that's one cappuccino
and one giant bag of Horton but I know
what a bag of horse yeah it's you know
it's kind of a two-for-one thing I want
the cappuccino you also have to pay for
a giant bag of horse well what if I just
want the cappuccino whoa buddy you start
making demands like that I will shut
down this entire coffee establishment
don't shut down the store you work at
yeah
it's absurd your job is to sell coffee
okay that is not in fact what is
happening the Republicans offered a
separate chip bill back in December
Democrats shot it down because Democrats
do not want spending offsets Republicans
included full funding for six years for
the chip bill in this current continuing
resolution Democrats tried to shut it
down anyway okay so that's not what's
happening this happens every time
there's a government shutdown every time
there's a government shutdown they put
forward to continuing resolution with a
lot of goodies in it to make the other
side look bad that's just the way that
it goes okay so that is what it is all
right time for a quick analysis of the
Federalist number 12 we go through a
federalist paper every week we've gone
through 11 of them already so we're now
at Federalist number 12 is Alexander
Hamilton talking about why a federal
government why strong nationalized
government is going to be able to gather
more revenue than state governments
would able would be able to be first
Hamilton gives a really good a really
good defense of capitalism here's what
he says this is quote it has been found
in various countries that in proportion
as Commerce has flourished land has
risen in value and how could it have
happened otherwise
could that which procures a freer event
for the products of the earth with
furnishes new incitements to the
cultivation of land which is the most
powerful instrument in increasing the
quantity of money in a state could that
in fine which is faithful handmade of
Labor and Industry in every shape failed
to augment that article which is
prolific parents afar the greatest part
of objects upon which that are exerted
that's complicated language for saying
it makes land more valuable in the
economy is good right believe it or not
this was not this was not actually
common knowledge back at the time
Hamilton was writing this he's read Adam
Smith some of the other founders had not
he says the Commerce creates revenue to
the federal government he says that he
recommends no direct taxation now it's
fascinating he's
the founders believed that the
government would not have the power to
actually levy an income tax there'd be
no direct taxation instead they were
forced to revert to what they called
excise taxes which were basically sales
taxes as well as tariffs now they spoke
out in favor of tariffs in a different
way than they would today because
Commerce today is so much easier so it
was a lot easier to control tariffs than
it would be today considering that the
United States had essentially one long
border and also the United States was
three weeks ride from any other place on
earth that was capable of trading with
it essentially he recommended excise
taxes and tariffs
he says it's evidence we must a long
time depend for the means of revenue
chiefly on such duties in most parts
excises must be confined within a narrow
compass the genius of the people will
ill brookie inquisitive and peremptory
spirit of excise laws she says we could
try to do sales tax and people are gonna
avoid it
he says the pockets of farmers on the
other hand will reluctantly yield but
scanty supplies in the unwelcome shape
of impositions on their houses so he
says the land tax probably won't do it
either especially because there's so
much land here for people to settle and
he says personal property is too
precarious and so we won't be able to do
that either a lot of the reason that
they did tariffs in the early days of
the of the United States is because it
was impossible to gather taxes any other
way not because they were in favor of
tariffs as a principle there's an
important point cuz a lot of people
today will suggest that tariffs were
something favored by the founders as
good trade policy that's not true the
founders were not all in favor of
tariffs in fact they only were using
tariffs because they had no other
available option for gathering tax
revenues right hehe suggest that
apparently there was a three percent
tariff essentially there was a fifteen
percent tariff in Britain and there was
a higher tariff in in France and a
higher tariff even in Britain he wanted
a nine percent tariff and suggested
beginning with an alcohol tax on a
terrifying alcohol that was coming into
the United States so that gives you
alone a background on the founding
ideology with regard to taxation which
was very light footstep and that's why
when people talk about how the founding
fathers would be anti-government shut
down the founding fathers would not care
at all the god founding fathers would
look at our tax rates and go are you out
of your damn minds are you guys crazy
are you crazy
and Hamilton sort of does that in
backhanded fashion in Federalist twelve
okay we back here tomorrow with the full
review of the Democrats caving on the
government shutdown I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and arrow
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018